there is jorge lopez making his
third start of the year see what he's
done so far era has elevated eight and
two-thirds
opponents hitting 306 off the
right-hander
2-2 pitch got him another good job so a
one two three inning for lopez
ends it by striking out gallo no score
we're heading to the second
oh yes right there at 97. got him
looking and that's four straight
strikeouts for jorge lopez
lopez is in a groove right now 97 miles
an hour
galvez tomahawk to high fastball for a
home run
against the mariners and hits this one
hard to center field
tavares racing back won't get there
short hops the wall
and galvez around second he's headed for
third
and ju he's in with a triple
oh there was no doubt he was going to
get to third because the centerfielder
tavares
didn't come up cleanly with it off the
wall he hit the home run his first home
of the year on
elevated fastball watch him go up again
and get this one this is just out of the
strike zone up where he hit the home run
he goes up and punish this ball almost
straight away center field
tavares gets to the right there fumbles
it goes right between his legs and
galvez never slowed down ends up at
third base and a really good start for
the orioles here in the top of the third
inning
deepest part of the park too out at the
410
and i think he's uh he's a high ball
hitter there's a shot to right field
gallow racing back
won't get it it's off the warning track
and cedric mullins with an rbi
base hit double yeah you talk about
finding the barrel there's that slider
again but this is not a good one just
kind of sitting right in the middle of
the plate and cedric mullins
knows exactly what to do with that one
joey gallo i thought had a chance to
catch this ball but
he just kept drifting and drifting and
never really turned around and ran
and luckily for the orioles it's over
his head orioles up one to nothing
runner on second
ball in two strikes two down orioles up
one nothing
texas third inning
looking again six strikeouts in just
three innings for jorge lopez
first pitch swinging ruiz fly ball it's
deep
center field way back it's gone rio ruiz
takes him for a ride and the orioles go
up
two-nothing on ruiz's second home run of
the year
boy he knew he had that one to a little
hop
by rio right before he left home plate
what a good piece of hitting that's a
good sign for rio when you start to
struggle with the plate you want to let
that ball
travel you want to let it get a little
bit deep we have just an instant of a
second to recognize it a little bit
longer
2-2 on the way and he's got him right on
the outside corner
another strikeout number eight for lopez
orioles on top
two nothing
looks like he's starting to get some
barrel on the ball here
well this offense is gonna hit there's
no doubt in my mind i mean it's gonna
get better than what it is
much better so many hitters that are 30
40 below points
points below their career averages
another high pitch and that's tattooed
into center field
it's in the gap finally run down by
tavares but galvez
is in with a double so a triple and a
double and two at bats for freddie
galvez
hit hard and passed into left field for
well he had a person third
had to make sure it got through right
you had to make sure it's kind of a line
drive so you got to make sure you see
his first moves back to the bag he's got
to make sure he's not
and that's the right move that's the
right move i mean you're taught as a
base runner at second base on the ground
ball
the ball has to be at you or behind you
mullins at first
orioles on top two nothing that should
get him in
deep center field tavares back makes a
good catch
galvez tags at third he'll score
and the orioles go up three nothing on
the rbi from anthony santander
orioles got a run in the third one in
the fourth and one more here in the
fifth inning that's it well
way back right field it is gone
d.j stewart first home run of the year
and it's a big one the orioles jump on
top
five nothing little happiness in that
oriole dugout
[Applause]
two-seam fastball misses the spot i mean
middle middle and you talk about
lean back on one watch this balance boom
is there any doubt he had that one
oriole bats have come to life
entirely another thing to have eight
strikeouts through four rings
smashes this one
well so much for that chuck's been doing
this for a long time
but man what a great swing from david
dahl
we talked about how it wasn't if but it
was when
lopez was bound to show a mistake at
some point
no hitter gone shutout gone rangers on
the board good way to start it
it's not if it's when
[Music]
that one just got over
nearly caught by santander and
solace does go back to back
and we talked about how when nick soloq
gets locked in
and he's going to the opposite field
he's going
[Applause]
to right field at santander because he
thought he came up with it
barely out of the reach of santander but
continues the home run trend
rangers have now struck out 13 times
first pitch hitting down to franco from
his knees back on his feet
and that's out number two nice play as
connor felipe
is retiring come on now who says michael
franco can't play a little d
this is an outstanding play here just a
rocket right to his glove side goes down
quickly transferred on his feet points
that shoulder
this is nice up strong throw across the
diamond
third baseman's have to play in a little
bit every now and then they don't call
it the hot corner for nothing
a ball and two strikes two down bottom
of the nine five two orioles
swinging a miss he got him valdez with
the strikeout to end it
earns his third save jorge lopez earns
his first win
and the orioles with a 5-2 winner in
arlington
as the rangers lose for the first time
after three straight wins